I love a neck tattoo what yes I love in
a tattoo and he likes guys that are
fresh out of prison I wouldn't I don't
like poser tattoos an owl like Winnie
the Pooh you know like those
Williamsburg tattoos no [ __ ] stamp no
whenever I meet a guy asked him to lift
up the back of his shirt hahaha there
you're going tattoo though you should
just do the holes go big or go home I
get intimidated by guys like that cuz I
think like wow you're like so cool meet
you I feel again not cool I don't have
any tattoos like I would love a guy with
some tats like some full sleeve half
sleeve I'm like yeah if I see something
with a sleeve it's a great conversation
piece you can like talk like what is
this Bulldog with a fried-chicken
tattoo that you have on God hey nice
bagel too nice everything bagel dad like
a neck tattoo don't fit don't get ever
get a neck tattoo I want you to have
like freshest dreams sorry
hey I want you to have diamonds and
pearls so I was back in like his triceps
he had like love peace oh and some other
word I think it was like community I had
a guy with a tattoo right here and it
said I miss you mom wish and I was like
I'm never going down on you what's a
mean Mannering Oh like if you're not
married and you're just wearing like the
cool ring don't wear a class ring and or
everywhere who would ever wear a class
ring I wear so much story I don't want
you wearing any dream dude no jewelry
watch oh I like the watch that's it a
watch a watch that's that's clean
don't be rolling up which a necklace
mm-hmm I have an ex-boyfriend who when I
look at his facebook profile now he's
wearing is like massive chains I'm sorry
I he's not flaking on I know he's I'm
not pulling it out I think unlike a
little necklace maybe you know not like
a shame not like a torture no I don't
want no change no it's good Oh in high
school graduated graduate high school
close